One of the things that's
important now to notice,
this these types of
transformations can be combined.
To achieve a transformation we
are taking single image and
then of course use that to
generate a translated image.
This has been translated.
Then of course I rotate
this image by amount theta.
And then of course I actually
add to it things like shear.
So in essence, this basically shows
that to get these set of parameters here
which basically now show translation,
this is where this comes in.
This kind of rotates the image
theta that we looked at.
And this of course,
also shears it by a certain amount and
shears it in this amount again
noted by these ratios here.
So of course x y w here can
be combined into this and
we can simplify this by looking at the
basically now there are nine parameters
here in this matrix and if we knew
these and combinations of these.
Of course, noting here that these
combinations can be done priory and
saved to and applied to imagery one.
Now one thing I may want to talk
about right here is most of the time
this i value would be 1.
Because remember, the current
condition we had with the ws.
W always wants to come out
to be a w on both sides.
And that would be the case here.
So most of the time,
we're looking for these 8 parameters.
Okay?
So let's look at what that means.